you see thank you for smoking also rob
lowes character that's what I envision
is this person that you said right you
know that one minute in it doesn't take
long for the first meeting because there
are there are certain buzzwords that
executives I guess in their twenty
minutes story training get told that
they will use and if someone uses that
early on a conversation you know like oh
we are you know I'm just curious what
they are know I'm look one big thing is
elevated genre we want this to be
elevated sure like what does it mean
yeah they want smart genre they want pop
up about sure but that doesn't help us
with the develop organic the characters
have to be organic it has to be
character driven it's these words
they're all true but there are cliches
they came out of a good observation so
if someone's only contribution during
the first meeting is to ask for a
character-driven elevated horror story
and on trouble because there's not gonna
be much actual help coming from from
that side you know so just kind of like
these catch it like I hear a lot of
Millennials use the words it's so meta
and I don't even know what or is so epic
like I so those kind of buzzwords cuz
I'm still trying to wrap my head around
like right I know what the word means
but in the context of like daily life
how is that how has that experience so
meta
I don't know in my age but you know what
I'm saying ya know that's and you know
that when you actually ask what that
means and ask them to define that there
is well you know like no I don't know
what what does that know how do you mean
organic right yeah and then you also get
ants certain certain buzz phrases to to
question like when you go like that and
that I think will be confusing they will
go like oh the audience today is smarter
than that really good that you can say
that to every story problem the audience
today is smarter than that
that is not an approach to actually so
when you get a series of those those
things you kind of know that yeah right
I see yeah
you